[Upbeat music]
- [Adam Lefkoe:] Underrated. Lefkoe!
Hot route.
Darrell Henderson! Hike!
[Suspenseful music]
[Laughing]
I'm worried that the camera's exploded.
[Instrumental music]
- Oh, what is up? What is good?
How ya livin'? How ya feelin'?
This is "Underrated." I am Adam Lefkoe.
This is the first show ever
that allows NFL players
to improve their Madden ratings.
It's brought to you by State Farm
and their surprisingly great rates.
Today, I got off the couch.
I came to California to
see Darrell Henderson
because he is having a
surprisingly great season.
I don't think people know
about it, especially Madden.
And we're gonna get those ratings up.
And I think he's here now.
Let's go talk to him.
[Instrumental music]
Hey, look at you getting ready!
- What up?
- How are you living?
- I'm good. How are you doing?
- I'm enjoying this L.A. air
right now. This is beautiful.
What's not beautiful
is your Madden rating.
It's bull crap. And I don't let—you're a 73.
- I don't know what's going on, but.
- Do you think you're underrated?
- I do. Like, I've been
underrated my whole life,
so it's--
- All right.
Well, we're gonna do some stuff today
to get that rating up.
- Let's get it.
- OK?
You sure?
- I'm ready.
- OK. I got a guy named Clint.
He's the guy we have to talk to, OK?
- All right.
- Let's get this going.
There he is.
Clint, my buddy, old pal!
How you feeling, buddy?
- Hey, I'm good. How're you doing, Lefkoe?
- I'm good. This is my good
friend, Darrell Henderson.
You may know him. He's on the Rams.
He's having an incredible
season this year.
- Yes, I know who Darrell is.
How you doing, Darrell?
Nice to see you.
- I'm doing good. How you doing?
- Doing well. What can
I do for you guys today?
- I've told him you're the plug.
And I wanna fix two ratings.
I wanna make them sky high
cuz I think my man is
killing it this season.
First one: Ball Carrier Vision.
Where is he right now?
And what do I need to have
him show you to bump it up?
- So his Ball Carrier Vision
rating currently is at 77.
- [Lefkoe:] Mmm.
- [Clint Oldenburg:] Currently ranking him 107.
- Ooh.
- [Lefkoe:] Do you think my friend is blind?
- Man, they got the practice
squads in front of me?
- Yeah, practice squad's in front of him.
What's the deal, Clint?
- That's mainly because we don't have
a ton of reps on Darrell yet,
but things that we're looking
for in Ball Carrier Vision,
uh, speed at which you find cutback lanes,
yardage efficiency, getting
through holes quickly.
Just maximizing that
burst through the line,
which I know is one of
Darrell's strengths.
- The second thing is
apparently my guy has
an absolute arm cannon.
I wanna focus on Throw Power.
- [Oldenburg:] That's a great question.
I don't hear that one
much for running backs.
I can give you a pretty
sizable increase in Throw Power
if you could throw over 60 yards.
- Easy.
- [Lefkoe:] Mmm.
I'm gonna have him do
all the things you asked.
We're gonna send you the footage.
You're gonna bump up the ratings.
And we're all gonna be smiles.
I appreciate you, Clint.
- [Oldenburg:] OK, I can't wait to see it, guys.
- OK.
Now that he's off the
phone, let's smoke this,
OK?
- We got to.
- Yes, let's go!
- [Laughing]
[Instrumental music]
- [Lefkoe:] It is Throw Power time.
You feel a little cocky
about this, don't you?
- No, I'm just confident.
- He's just confident.
Let me bring it down to size
because we are comparing it
to your Madden character.
Have you seen yourself
throw in Madden yet?
- No.
- It's not a pretty sight.
Let's take a look.
There he is: 27, Darrell
Henderson. Drops back, throws,
and that's about as far as you can throw.
40 yards, Darrell Henderson.
Is that insulting to
who you are as a person?
- Yes.
- I'm insulted for you.
If you throw it further than
40, your rating goes up.
The further you go, the higher it goes up.
- Then let's go.
- OK. Get this out of
here. It's bad evidence.
[Instrumental music]
Are you ready?
- Let's go.
- [Lefkoe:] OK.
[Instrumental music continues]
Darrell, there is no way
your Madden character
is throwing that far.
[Beep]
[Instrumental music continues]
Look at Darrell with the beautiful throw!
[Beep]
I think that was further.
Does that feel good?
- Yeah.
- [Lefkoe:] Oh, that's the one.
[Beep]
I gotta do some pushups.
This is intimidating.
All right, this is the last one.
Do you think you can hit 70?
- Let's go.
[Suspenseful music]
- [Lefkoe:] Get there, get there, get
there, get there, get there.
What did it hit, Jacob?
- [Jacob:] 11.
- The 11!
[Beep]
69!
How does the cannon feel?
- Good.
- Man, see, and this is why
his ratings need to go up.
Because he is willing to tire out his arm
in a game week for "Underrated."
OK, so we know that you can throw it,
but if we're really gonna
change your Madden rating,
I need to see the vision,
that Ball Carrier Vision.
We don't have your offensive line,
but I do have these guys.
[Instrumental music]
So here's how we're gonna do this.
I'm getting under center.
I'm bringing it back.
And when you get the rock,
they're gonna open up.
Wherever the hole is, hit it
and then juke out the linebacker cam.
Does this sound good to you?
- I'm with it. I'm ready.
- Let's go.
[Instrumental music]
- [Lefkoe:] OK.
Set!
Darrell Henderson. Hike!
Hey!
I think we need to embarrass the camera.
I think whatever you
do on this next move,
just embarrass it.
Underrated. Lefkoe!
Hot route.
Darrell Henderson. Hike!
[Instrumental music]
[Laughing]
I'm worried that the camera's exploded.
Madden, I mean, we're breaking
cameras to improve this rating.
Man.
- Stiff-armed it down there.
- [Lefkoe:] Ahh!
All right, this is the last one.
EA, Clint: This is a big one.
Oldenburg! Clint Oldenburg!
Darrell Henderson! Hike!
Way to be, Darrell!
All you did was break a camera today.
Proud of you. How did it feel?
- It felt pretty good.
- All right, tell the people first:
How are my handoff skills?
- It was great.
- Except when I went that way, right?
- Yeah, you had a little difficulty at the beginning.
- That's OK.
Offensive line was
great. You threw it deep.
Showed off the arm cannon.
Overall, do you have a
message for the people of EA?
- Get my ratings up.
Stop playing with me.
- Stop playing with him.
Darrell Henderson. Get
the ratings up now!
[Instrumental music]
- Clint, buddy, pal, I've missed you a lot.
And I'm so excited
because Darrell Henderson
is showing everybody this
season he's the most underrated.
I know you see the stiff-arms.
- He is coming up, man.
I wish the Rams would commit
to him a little bit more.
Get him more carries in that backfield.
But he is opening some eyes for sure.
- I'm lovin' it.
And now I need you to say this to his face,
that he's underrated.
Let's get Darrell Henderson on the call.
My guy!
Darrell, I mean, listen.
Ever since I've seen,
you've been killing people, dude.
It's amazing to watch, man.
We're proud of ya.
- Appreciate it.
- Clint, first thing, Throw Power.
- Oh, my gosh, so that was impressive.
I didn't know that he had
an arm on him like this.
He threw it almost 70 yards
in the air on both throws.
So his Throw Power is actually
going up 22 points to a 55,
and he's now the fourth
running back in Throw Power,
right below a teammate of his,
who was a former quarterback, Cam Akers.
- Yeah, we might have to have a throw-off
in the Rams backfield here.
Clint, we got the sumo
wrestlers out there,
the offensive line for
some Ball Carrier Vision.
Was the tape good enough
to improve that for you?
- Darrell was already increasing
based on his game film this season.
It is now going up to an 80.
He's gonna now be ranked
63rd among all running backs
in Ball Carrier Vision.
So he's moved up 44 spots
in Ball Carrier Vision
since we last spoke.
- Darrell, your thoughts.
- We're off to a good start,
but I think I'm about a 92.
[Laughing]
- That's not all.
Based on the tape, there's
a bonus point.
- Hey.
- Awareness.
Awareness is also going up one point.
That will raise your
overall rating, Darrell.
So you've moved up to a 75 overall
with all of these updates.
- Let's go!
- Ooh.
I'm saying you're underrated.
Social media is saying you're underrated.
Clint, is Darrell Henderson underrated?
- Darrell Henderson is underrated,
and if I could, I wanna make
a plea to Coach Sean McVay:
Get the ball in this guy's
hands a little bit more.
I wanna see more of him.
- Yeah, so I gotta keep working,
keep improving, week by week.
- Darrell, so proud of you.
And candidly, the only
thing more surprising
than your phenomenal
performance this year...
Clint, what is it?
- Insurance?
- Exactly!
The surprisingly great
rates of State Farm!
That's "Underrated" and
that's one heck of a segue.
Darrell Henderson, way to go, pal!
[Instrumental music]
[Whistle]